hello and welcome to feed bakula the
show that snuffles through the
wilderness of the comments section like
a truffle pig and like a truffle pig it
wade through quite a lot of poop to get
there coming up today Batman Batman can
do whatever his high-tech gadgets allow
him to yes this week's or the spiffy
trailer announcement for batman arkham
knight the next installment in the Cape
Crusaders capers after the last game
Arkham origins the franchise is coming
back to rock steady the British studio
who made the first title Kevin Conroy is
also returning to voice the Batman and
for the first time you'll be able to get
behind the wheel of the Batmobile
understandably there was a fair amount
of excitement oh jeez my adrenaline went
over acceptable limits just now I very
much hope this game turns out to be
amazing burg azum yes after the mediocre
Arkham origins made by WB Montreal
Rocksteady back to take over and give us
a great Batman game can't wait after
four games you get to track the stinking
Batmobile so where they're going to
people people in the streets this time
haha I've got no idea what you're asking
me because that makes no sense haha
Kevin Conroy is back good very good ok
no more meaty Batman with fat forearms
now I'm starting to care hey people with
fat forearms have feelings too you know
of course while most people were excited
there were a few with considerably less
enthusiasm for Arkham Knight some when
asked what they learned replied thus we
learned that they intend to meld the
franchise for what it's worth we learned
that a game that deserved a sequel to is
becoming an annualised franchise by
greedy publisher exploit us please
Mama's gonna do something else instead
of swimming around Arkham all the time
how about not a broken game this time
huh will this turn out like the last one
where they rather push out dlc instead
of fix
bugs different developer Fox tick check
the facts well that's not the most
polite way of putting it but yes it is a
different developer this time round you
stick on the hole then people are happy
the Arkham franchise has returned to
rock steady but that's not all there's
another big different setting Arkham
Knight apart from origins multiplayer
multiplayer Arkham Knight won't have
multiplayer yeah saying they don't have
time for multiplayer because they want
to make a better single-player
experience Rocksteady is throwing over
the mode entirely ensuring you'll be
exploring our chem and breaking noses
all by your lonesome ordinarily you'd
think this would be enough to whip
commenters into a swearing rage but in
actuality they seem kind of pleased glad
to see Rocksteady going against the
grain when it comes to multiplayer being
shoehorned and forced into I peas and
franchisees but just don't need them I
wonder if we'll be able to run over
enemies with the Batmobile screw you
multiplayer good riddens I hope all
next-gen games follow suit and abandon
multiplayer gaming got ruined by all
this co-op and multiplayer [ __ ] it's
time proper games with good
single-player campaigns came out I
missed such games for too long I
appreciate your enthusiasm but I think
titanfall might struggle a bit if the
multiplayer mode got taken away yes [ __ ]
multiplayer the cheat mush up the tailed
me from buying origins along with the
crappy developer hell yeah no
multiplayer I enjoy playing with myself
oh wait wanking gag wanking gag that
user made a wanking gag no multiplayer
with me doesn't have a problem with it
but the game better off without it I
just don't seem to get why people hate
multiplayer these days don't get me
wrong it's more important to focus on
single player but what's wrong if
someone decides to add a multiplayer
mode after but people still going to
complain I just don't get a lot of
things these days steady on charge man
1991 if that's your
birth year then you're not even 25 don't
write yourself off as senile just yet I
think the reason people take issue with
multiplayer being tacked on two games is
that it takes a lot of time to get right
and it's time that could be spent on the
single player especially if the
multiplayer then sucks take far cry 3
for example great game really strong
single-player campaign nutsack
multiplayer mode nutsack mode nutsack
mode far cry 3 nutsack multimode so
while a few people may miss the
multiplayer mode when Arkham Knight
launches it's nice to see a developer
stepping up and saying it's not actually
essential that's all from me for this
week I'll be back next time when she
wait a minute if I'm in singing the
spider-man theme this whole time yeah i
was gonna ask about actually ah [ __ ]